ce but de propulser vers sa huitième
tour de la coupe de france ce dimanche
18 novembre les versaillais ont réussi à
se qualifier face au club tahitien des
dragons au score final 2 à 0 on est
satisfait d'être passé de passer le tour
c'est une satisfaction c'était une chose
qu'on avait à coeur de faire et
l'essentiel a été fait et des buts en
première mi temps après on aurait aimé
marquer plus de buts en seconde période
mais bon tant qu'il ya la qualif au bout
c'est ce qu'on voulait pourtant rien n'a
été simple face à des polynésiens qui
ont joué leur chance à fond malgré un
voyage de 16 mille kilomètres comme sur
cette frappe sur le poteau de l'ancien
joueur de ligue 1 rabat rabat erreur on
a beaucoup travaillé mais notre lumière
adversaires aujourd'hui c'était quand
même le soir et le vent donc du coup si
compliqué pour nous surtout quand on
vient ici en pleine période chaude chez
nous avec un taux d'humidité qui passe
qui dépasse les 100%
après cette qualification versailles
reste le dernier club il doit encore en
course dans la compétition le club
n'avait plus atteint 8e tour de coupe de
france depuis sept ans ça fait plaisir
maintenant on va voir si on va voir le
prochain tirage sinon notre faveur ou
pas dans tous les cas on va essayer de
faire un joli parcours cette année
ça dépend de l'adversaire comme vous
dites qu'on va me dire on va lui mettre
le coeur le tirage au sort du 8e tour
sera effectué ce mardi 20 novembre à 19h
les versets y et pourrait recevoir un
club de ligue 2 la rencontre se
disputera quant à elle le 8 décembre
prochain